a site we're more used to seeing in the
tropics this is one of three tornadoes
tearing through western germany
leaving dozens injured and a trail of
destruction in their wake
there are also reports of death here in
the city of paderborn there were winds
of 81 miles per hour
uprooting trees
ripping through roofs and scattering
debris for miles
those used to be solar panels but this
woman was left with twisted scraps and a
sense of disbelief the hyzers
the houses are destroyed lots of cars
destroyed car dealerships i just drove
by i thought really 20 minutes ago the
world was totally fine nothing was going
on it was just raining but for a wind
like that to go through you only know
that from the u.s from tv
south
south chimpanzee
[Music]
the german weather service warned of
heavy rainfall and strong gusts but even
the emergency services are struck by the
scale of the damage
yeah by whistling
yes in bigger buildings the roofs have
been damaged by the extreme wind and
actually all buildings have no roof
anymore windows are broken and it looks
like a disaster area here
across the continent in spain a contrast
in conditions and a very different type
of extreme
it may be good weather for the beach but
this is the beginning of a heat wave
temperatures in some places forecast to
exceed 42 degrees celsius
blazing heat they usually see in the
summer
the weather this weekend is more than a
tale of two countries it is a reminder
here in europe the impact of our
changing climate is no longer beneath
the surface
shingi maurike sky news